the only um the only tournament arjun
played last season was the golden asian
rap but he did make it to the quarter
finals to face levon right yes
could you have it so like you've got
eight people who qualify the top four
pick who they play
just to have it like a little bit of
drama because it's like why are you
picking me you know it's like you know
so the person who comes top can pick his
opponent or pick her opponent i think
that'd be quite it'd be quite
controversial because it's like you know
you can really hone in on people it's
like oh come on but it could be quite
interesting yeah and it's kind of the
opposite from when you have uh pickings
in gym class for example you want to be
the one picked first here it's kind of
yeah i don't know and that's clear we
have a result uh jew and jun has lost to
anish geary
three points for anish three very
important points for anish but now it's
looking very good for him to qualify for
the knockout stage it's looking
very bad for jew wenjun
perhaps